et vous aviez presque commencé à
répondre déjà prochaines municipales
mars 2014 serait ou non candidat bernard
demain je l' ai déjà dit oui quand vous
serez candidat est ce que vous serez
tête de liste donc bah oui naturellement
faute vous êtes déjà en campagne ou pas
non non la campagne bon je pense que
c'est comme tous les maires je pense que
la campagne on la fait tous les jours
quel sera le thème est bien un timing
vous êtes posé un timing tout de même
non pas tellement comment ce mode occupé
avant les vacances avant les grandes
vacances pour constituer la liste par
exemple ben avant les grandes vacances
et des discussions qui sont déjà en
cours
pas du tout nous attendent et que chacun
se manifestent vous repartez avec la
même équipe n'ont pas la même équipe
parce que y en a un certain nombre qui
ont quand même eux qui ont pris de l'âge
et donc il pourra qui y ait un
renouvellement mais je pense que il ya
un noyau dur les puis autour du quai
lombard remonter quelque chose vous avez
été élu en 2006 depuis le mandat a été
un petit peu agitée d'une quelques
dissidents certains remis mais votre
majorité
comment vous expliquer cette tension qui
ont eu lieu depuis 2006 des
démissionnaires il y en a eu cinq ou six
en tout cas les gens qui ont quitté
votre majorité
oui certains avaient les dents longues
certains réclamaient des postes il y en
a même qui les réclamaient deux jours
après l'élection
donc qu'ils n'avaient pas traîné
vous n'avez pas assez réfléchi avant de
constituer votre liste à l'époque non
c'est pas une question de réflexion je
pense que j'étais peut-être un peu naïf
la sude ce côté là et pour moi si vous
voulez quand on n'a jamais fait partie
d'une équipe municipale
je pense qu'il ya un temps de
d'apprentissage et que du jour au
lendemain on n'est pas forcément adjoint
surtout quand on n'a pas aussi une
disponibilité
parce que quand je vois le les heures
que par certains de mes adjoints par les
deux tiers mes adjoints passent plus de
30 ou 40 heures par semaine en mairie en
mairie ou dans les services donc c'est
faux une énorme disponibilité nous
parliez tout à l'heure de la zac renard
et lors de la signature justement de
cette de cette signature entre l'état
pardon et puis l aménageur il ya eu un
homme dont les habitants de saint cyr
l'école se souviennent sans doute
philippe lavaud c'est l'ancien maire de
millas en 2006 ump également
il a démissionné alors qu'il était sous
le coup d'une procédure pénale pour
diffamation il a été relaxé depuis en
pourquoi sa présence tout simplement
parce que au même titre que je l'avais
invité lorsque j'avais inauguré la
piscine la piscine municipale en 2007
parce que cet accès comme vous disiez
tout à l'heure ses dix ans et il ya dix
ans c'est lui qui a lancé l'opération
donc je trouvais tout à fait normal
qu'il soit là à la conclusion
il se dit aussi qu'il pourrait être
candidat en 2014 sur votre liste aussi
bas en tous les cas non moi je suis pas
au courant
il souhaitait alors on est trop court
mais ce que vous le souhaitez non pas du
tout je lui ai déjà dit d'ailleurs je
lui ai dit je pense que
il a choisi de démissionner c'est pas
pour revenir un mandat après donc vous
nous dites aujourd'hui de janvier en
mars 2014 il ne sera pas sur ma liste
fils mon âme ou non la voiture malines
où il sera pas sur menu ce ne sera pas
sur votre liste donc pour ces prochaines
municipales compense en tout cas
l'opposition de ce retour de philippe
lavaud nous avons posé la question on se
retrouve ensuite sur le plateau pour
continuer cet entretien je botte du tout
envie de participer à ce genre de débat
il fait ce qu'il veut vous savez
lorsqu'on pense bernard de bain qu'en
pensent les scintillants je pense que
les saint cyriens souviennent qui les a
laissés tomber brutalement en plein
milieu d'un mandat avec des choses quand
même pas très clair avec notamment un
procureur de la république qui avait
quand même lancé une enquête sur ses
petites affaires
il fait ce qu'il veut philippe lavaud
puis saint cyrien décideront mais nous
on est je vous dis d'en essayer de
construire quelque chose avec des gens
convient de se battre pour leur ville
des gens propres des gens qui ont de
l'énergie parce que ça manque beaucoup
aujourd'hui
vous partagez point de vue donné alpha
renier sur ce point là
philippe lavaud ne devrait pas en tout
cas revenir on rappelle aussi qu'il
avait été condamné en 2004 à cinq
reprises pour des attentats la
démocratie et locale ça fait partie de
l'ensemble des dossiers qui ont été
compliqués à gérer à l'époque dans la
ville témoin je faisais pas je n'étais
pas là l'époque j'étais même pas membres
du conseil municipal donc mais tout ce
que je sais si vous voulez c'est que
c'est toujours dit il a pris une
décision en 2006 de se retirer je pense
que
on pas pourquoi il reviendrait vite en
prêt ou neuf ans après donc moi j'ai
toujours dit j'ai fait une équipe et
j'ai une équipe à l'heure actuelle dont
beaucoup vont repartir avec moi et
j'estime que là dedans il y a des gens
qui seront ceux qui prendront la suite
le jour où j'arrêterai parce que moi je
suis pas éternel non mais vous évoquez
philippe lavaud nous dit il ne sera pas
sur ma liste ans en 2014 pour autant en
le conviant sur les cérémonies comme les
signatures
vous entretenez un petit peu aussi ça ce
mystère candidat par candidat sur ma
liste ma soeur ma liste non non c'est de
la politesse c'est de la politesse
voyez c
j'ai personnellement je suis toujours
prêt à accueillir ceux qui ont travaillé
pour la ville
même si je suis pas d'accord avec eux
vous ne vous en souvenez peut-être pas
mais lorsque l'on a rénové la plaine de
jeux j'ai souhaité qu'elle s'appelle
plaine de jeux gens qui gaine et
pourtant jean cuguen a été à la tête
d'une équipe qui n'a jamais paru mémoire
côté de mon bord politique après thomas
g je les fais pourquoi parce que il ya
un certain nombre de choses qui ont été
faites à son époque de construction de
reconstruction de la ville pour lequel
jeudi j'avais dit à l'époque
chapeau parce qu' il fallait le faire 1
c'était pas comme ça que l'aurait fait
j'aurais peut-être mis un peu plus de
d'entreprise un peu plus deux autres
d'activité mais j'estimais que c'était
normal et ça permet de dépasser les
querelles et les polémiques
voilà une dernière série de questions
politiques pour terminer cette édition
est ce que l'ump peut se rassembler pour
2013 vous avez été déçu de l'année 2012
l'ump en général l'ump au plan national
l'ump au plan des 120 naturellement
qu'ils vont se rassembler parce que ça
aura aussi des courses un gros succès
dans les départements on peut rappeler
aussi que dans les départements des
yvelines valérie pécresse qui souhaite
mais france ronny mais je pense que les
coréens d'hommes elles vont passer tout
ce qui est important c'est les idées
et puis je crois justement vous parliez
de de gens comme valérie pécresse mais
il ya aussi gérard larcher qui est côté
de françois pignon fillon mais
le député de rambouillet mais ce poisson
il y a
monsieur
jean-marie tard tout à fait
il ya monsieur pierre lequiller ya donc
un certain nombre de gens qui sont de
plus tôt du côté de monsieur copé qui le
soutenaient mais ce sont des gens billon
une volonté c'est que l'ump se
rassemblent de façon à être capable
d'avoir un à la fois pour les élections
municipales et principalement dans les
grandes villes
et puis aussi au plan national il faut
des gens qui parlent d'une seule voix et
le meilleur moyen de parler d'une seule
voix c'est d'abord une seule direction
donc la thur helmand que ça va se faire
le reste c'est bon c'est une querelle de
personnes entre sujet le mariage pour
tous vous êtes contre le mariage pour
tous vous l'avez dit oui je les dis il
ne ferait pas de célébration de mariage
des homosexuels dans votre commune la
loi cible il ya une manif et très
sereine je vais dire demain que je peux
épouse ebah tiens pourquoi pas ma fille
ma nièce bien ces mariages pour tous
moi j'ai toujours dit que la chose la
plus importante c'était l'enfant ce qui
me gêne c'est ngo le mot mariage alors
si c'est juste le nom mariage pour tous
si ces mots pour tout ce qui vous gêne
au final on sait pas le mot beauté pour
le mot mariage
j'ai toujours dit je l'écris dans ma
chronique je le décris en alger 10
appelons ça autrement
appelons ça union civile moi je pensais
que le pacs répondait déjà bien ça si
les gens venus de cérémonie appelons ça
ou alors qu'on enlève carrément le mon
mariage parce que le mariage c'est quoi
c'est un habillage que la révolution a
fait pour
passé par devant ce que l église à
l'époque mais en fait s'il faut enlever
le mot mariage à ce qui se passe à la
mairie moi je veux bien mais c'est si
vous voulez ce qui me gêne c'est pas il
ya ça mais il ya ce qu'il va y avoir
derrière c'est les enfants la
procréation médicalement assistée et
séné mère porteuse valorisation le 13
janvier à paris contre le mariage pour
tous enregistrés oui naturellement je
serai présent le 13 janvier à paris et
puis un tout dernier sujet nous reste
très peu de temps mais on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir au cours des
prochaines semaines c'est la mosquée
pour la communauté musulmane de saint
cyr l'école et de fontenay également une
salle de prix et on va dire la barre en
tout cas la communauté musulmane par
plus de mosquées inter entre les deux
communes de saint cyr et fontenay existe
fontenay a fait le nécessaire pour que
la construction puisse se faire et eu
des modifications
est ce que la mère de fontenay soutient
la création
oui dès maintenant il sent il me semble
il semble qu'il manque la position du
maire de saint cyr l'école quelle est
votre position sur ce nom si c'est pas
comme ça que ça se passe
si vous vous laissez c'est moi le
premier qui est dit qu' il fallait
trouver un terrain pourquoi un terrain
parce que il faut avouer que les
musulmans puissent prier dans des
conditions dignes
non seulement des conditions dignes mais
en plus des conditions acceptables en
termes de sécurité
à l'heure actuelle il prit à saint cyr
dans un à petit appartement et dans les
caves
mais est-ce que les terrains qui a été
trouvée se désole qu'on ait pris par le
temps mais est ce que le terrain qui a
été trouvée vous êtes d'accord avec le
ter qui me va me va très bien
donc vous fait le nécessaire pour qu'il
y avait des relations que celle ce
terrain à va très bien c'est moi même
qui avait évoqué cette possibilité
le terrain appartient à la ville de
fontenay mais situées sur le territoire
de saint gilles il est à l'heure
actuelle en zone non constructible
quand ils m'ont quoi aujourd'hui
concrètement de la part de la commune iv
saint cyr l'école pour que ça puisse se
faire et bien pour que ça puisse se
faire pourrait viser le pnud est ce que
ça peut aller vite un pays luz un an
avant une élection municipale
non ça fera parler eridan ça fera partie
de votre votre campagne de vos points de
campagne mais je dois aller recevoir la
semaine prochaine
j'ai toujours dit il ya un certain
nombre de petits choses à voir entre
autres pour des raisons de de
stationnement mais sur un terrain qui
cette fois ci appartient à la ville j'ai
une idée
c'est quelque chose qui va se faire de
façon à ce que ce qui se passe dans les
calmes n'existe plus à la droite il y
aura sept salles de prière ou où cette
mosquée en tout cas sur cette ville 200
siens l'école l'arrêt de travail de
chantenay et vous nous l'avez dit
réunion a prévu la semaine prochaine
donc avec cette communauté musulmane
merci par-devant d'être venu sur ce
plateau et vous nous l'avez dit
également vous serez candidat en 2014 et
la liste pour l'instant n'est pas encore
constitué vous aurez le temps encore de
la faire il reste quinze mois avant les
prochaines élections prochaines éditions
du 7 8
ce sera demain en toujours en direct dès
18h sur notre site internet vous
retrouvez l'intégralité de
nos vidéos en consultation libre
excellente soirée et puis bien sûr
excellente année une fois de plus